c'est un rendez vous organisé par rai tv
60,18 le troisième festival saint
quentin débute officiellement ce soir
événement dédié aux films documentaires
jusqu'à dimanche à saint quentin en
yvelines
bonsoir nicolas kirillovitch vous êtes
sur place à l'ugc et skywest et dans
quelques minutes début de la cérémonie
d'ouverture de ce festival qui a pour
thème cette année la musique
bonsoir qui n'aurait en effet la musique
est à l'honneur cette année la ville
sous tous ses aspects que ce soit à
travers le parcours d'un artiste de son
importance pédagogique dans nos vies ou
même de son importance historique pour
de nombreuses communautés et pour
débuter ce festival à l'ugc et skyways
dans quelques instants le célèbre
compositeur de musique de film vladimir
cosma sera mise à l'honneur
vous le connaissez forcément vladimir
cosma puisqu'il a composé notamment la
musique d'un dîner de cons de rabbi
jacob ou encore de la boum pour ne citer
qu'eux une soirée autour d'un piano pour
retracer le parcours de l'artiste
et pour en parler nous sommes avec le
directeur de l'ugc à mes côtés marc
albaut grave s bonsoir détaillé nous un
petit peu cette cette soirée comment
elle va se dérouler concrètement je veux
parler d'une d'une soirée autour d'un
piano c'est de ça dont il s'agit
alors oui il n'ya pas que ça y'a pas
qu'un canot vu qu'en première partie il
y aura l'ensemble musical de
montigny-le-bretonneux qui va jouer
pendant une demi heure trois quarts
d'heure des musiques de films dont on ne
savait pas mais une musique de vladimir
cosma donc qui fera en salle et après il
ya la lumière cosma qui va présenter un
documentaire un peu sur son oeuvre sur
sa vie sur ses compositions et il va
interagir avec patrice carmouze au piano
discuter de ses compositions
voilà pendant toute la soirée on entend
justement les répétitions ont débuté ce
soir pour la première soirée vous faites
vous fait je crois ça me comble c'est un
bon signal pour la pour la suite du
festival forcément alors oui c'est un
bon signal on à peu près 400 personnes
ce soir qui seront présents dans la
salle
mais ce soir c'est l'ouverture mais le
festival a commencé dès ce matin avec
des premières projections de films et de
documentaires à l'ugc ou pour l'instant
le public répond présent évidemment il y
en aura encore pendant jusqu'à dimanche
des films alger c'est peut être un mot
sur votre partenariat avec ceux avec ce
festival c'est par la première année
c'est une affaire qui on va dire qu'il
commença à entrer dans les us et
coutumes c'est une affaire qui roule
entre vous alors écoutez ça va faire
maintenant la troisième année c'est un
festival qu'on a imaginé avec thierry
valette de tv 78 donc c'est vrai qu'on
voulait créer un événement au niveau de
l'agglomération pour essayer de fédérer
un peu toutes les forces au niveau de la
culture donc c'est la troisième édition
dédiée à la musique on a déjà fait
l'environnement notamment au niveau de
la coque 21 on a fait une manière le
sport et cette année on voulait vraiment
créer quelque chose de très fédérateur
autour de la musique où tout le monde va
se retrouver et avec des moments très
forts notamment à l'ugc avec des moments
classique des moments un peu plus
moderne et notamment deux événements
classiques
1 le vendredi soir avec les enfants de
verdi ou la hausse y aura une cantatrice
qui viendra en salle jouée au canot avec
les enfants de trappes pour chanter du
verdi et dimanche après-midi vous aurez
un opéra ballet qui s'appelle les amants
magnifiques et sera retransmis à l'ugc
merci alban grave s pour ces précisions
donc vous l'aurez compris grégory
dernière petite précision d'ailleurs sur
le programme on peut se rendre sur le
site internet du festival
c'est jusqu'à dimanche en tout cinquante
manifestations sont prévues donc ici
évidemment à l'ugc skate mais aussi en
partenariat avec l'ue vs q le grenier à
sel et le ciné 7 d'elancourt merci à
vous à nicolas et à patrick jacques de
dixmude aux moyens techniques la soirée
de clôture ce festival elle se tient ce
dimanche au ciné c'est d'elancourt dès
16 heures avec une remise des prix et
chaque jour à partir de demain sur tv
soixante dix huit nouveaux à proposant
la diffusion de documentaires consulter
la programmation de ce festival saint
quentin sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran